close it out with a kinder stinger and
this is a man right here
hey yo king in the sting what up brendan
what up theo what up culture corner
shout out nick and chin love the content
love you guys
channel makes me laugh so much i'm gonna
make this short and sweet
king it or sting it what you guys think
about
uh that wall hanging hitter
put a urinal in your bathroom i just
remodeled this whole thing
had to put the urinal in i got a toilet
too
it's got plenty of that tp with that
wall hanging hitter
are you rich for the number ones what do
you think
gang gang buzz buzz dang gang man i love
that i've never
seen that in a human home
uh in kindergarten sam basil's family
had one it was awesome all right don't
brag
don't brag wow and so and what is it
it's a oh just a urinal you can go use
it
yeah like like a like a restroom year oh
dude what a
upgrade i've never seen that pretty nice
but i'm able to just go out into my
living room and just order applebee's or
something like that's the only thing i
i wonder if i'll just like get
disillusioned where i am you know
growing up my uncle was rich and he had
a bidet and i used to think it was a
water fountain
oh oh
a drink out of it so that's how we got
here
not shocked buddy yeah really shocked by
that
my older brother used to tell me as a
water fountain really yep
would it spray far like it would spray
all up in my face
ah yes got that
[Music]
is